[Music]
education especially education for
children maximizing the potential of
kids into our world how do we best do
that and we'll be unpacking the nuance
of that with two very brilliant
panelists first to my left is Vicki
Vicki Alger is a research fellow at the
independent Institute in Auckland and
holds senior fellowships at the Fraser
Institute headquartered in Vancouver and
independent women's forum in Washington
DC so her research focuses on education
reform that promote a competitive
education marketplace and increased
parent's control over their children's
education which actually I learned
earlier that Arizona is one of the
leading content will control over
education states which was really
interesting and Florida's up there too
yes we have friendly competition between
Arizona and Florida and then she's also
advised the US Department of Education
on public school choice in higher
education reform and she's the author of
more than 40 education policy studies
and four books most recently failure the
federal miss education of America's
children and then Carroll Kosovar has
worked to improve public education ever
since her 2 children attended public
schools in San Francisco she's past
president of the California State PTA
and has advocated for adequate school
funding small class sizes arts for all
children special education funding
physical education and counselors civics
education in the defeat of vouchers she
has worked as a journalist and attorney
and Ombudsperson
for special education she hosts looking
at education on klw radio 91 7 FM an SF
and as a writer for ed 100 orga web
resource to create informed parent
leaders yes
[Applause]
so this is one of the most pressing
issues that we face is figuring out how
to educate children into our world and
what are I guess the basics that we need
to know about figuring out how to
educate kids into our world this is a
public good should this be made
available to everybody and how should it
be made available to everybody the
quality of education well I'd like to
defer to my host or San Francisco the
answer is yes
public education education for all
children education so that every child
has an opportunity to develop to learn
not only English and math and science
but learn how to work with other
children learn about the importance of
responsibility civic responsibility I
think that that probably is the most
important role that we have as citizens
and that is educating the next
generation so yes the answer is yes it's
important and then maybe a follow-up to
that is then how what Annie can chime in
here would be how do we then fund and
provide equal opportunity for all kids
in all socio-economic statuses well I
would say that Carol and I absolutely
agree on that point and one thing that
was interesting to me in researching my
book failure is did we always educate
children the way we do today and the
answer is absolutely not at the
beginning of our Republic it was very
diverse and so you have so many much of
the researchers in the original colonies
there's less data on the south but what
was very interesting is every community
every Township it was very unique and
I'm originally from Boston so I like to
pick on Boston and we bet and so it was
interesting in Boston
they started doing research I call them
the Boston busybodies because we're very
worried about oh my goodness
we don't have a system we don't we don't
track children we don't know what what
about the poor children and so the
Boston busybodies did a survey about
where all these poor children going to
school and our parents sending their
children to school well guess what the
results of the survey were 98 percent of
the children poor regardless of
socioeconomic status were actually being
educated now the way they were being
educated was there were schools there
were tutors if families could not afford
because everything was you have to pay
for something there was no system of
publicly financing all children being
educated and so once they got the
results back it's like ooh this doesn't
really fit our agenda if someone has
there has to be an expert in charge so
then they said well we really need
experts because we can't trust these
parents or these private entities or
these private tutors or heaven forbid
religious organizations contributing so
we would agree on there should be
universal education where I think there
may be disagreement is who you know
through whom do we fund it and should
government be involved because one thing
being in San Francisco I like to
acknowledge that this was this was the
place that Nobel laureate laureate
economist Milton Friedman chose to call
home and to summarize just because we
fund schools through government doesn't
mean that government knows what's best
for over 50 million of other people's
children and I think we've gone down a
path we're out of genuine concern to
make sure that all children have access
to education it's been homogenized it
doesn't work for all children yet we
don't allow them an escape hatch so I
think that's where the conversation
needs to happen how can we achieve
equity access and a four
and really excellent education for all
children yes well said I was we had the
pleasure of being at the Southland Tech
Center in Boston Meltemi Susan Clem
sacks no checked and we had a chance to
interview them and I mean their main
point is that the closer that children
are to the information superhighway mmm
and the more that they have access to
that the better their life outcome is
and so then how to provide the
educational superhighway this
informational superhighway next to every
child is a choice of government helping
50 million kids private industry coming
in making free we also work with the
ck-12
Foundation which provides amazing
simulations and across physics and
chemistry and all these different
Sciences so should how should we figure
out what is best for every individual
child well I think you've hit upon the
point of disagreement and my sense is
that as a country as a community our
most important responsibility as a
government is to make sure all of our
children have access to a quality
education now of course you know we look
at the history of of the world things
don't always work out there there always
can be improvement but the ideal the
sense that we and our government and I
used the government meeting us as a
community have a responsibility to make
sure that we meet the needs of all of
our children if you take a little look
at some of the history it wasn't always
that all children had access to school
it wasn't always particularly left if we
look at children with special needs or
disabilities that they had access to
schools and I think it's very important
that there be a commitment on the part
of all of us that our government provide
a free appropriate public education for
every single child and I think we
disagree
in some ways but I don't think we
disagree on on some things and some of
the things I think that we would agree
on that we would agree on is we're not
disagreeing on whether or not there
should be choice because there is a lot
of choice within a strong public
education system if you look here in San
Francisco our our whole school system is
a system of choice we have magnet
schools we have language schools we have
schools that specialize in the art and
children have an opportunity to choose
to go to those kinds of schools when I I
came to San Francisco one of the reasons
that I moved to San Francisco was there
was choice within our public school
system absolutely excellent schools and
so my children have the opportunity to
go through I thought absolutely terrific
public schools here in San Francisco so
I think that that it is a difference in
thought I don't believe quite frankly
that when you say that we have to have
all our children on the information
superhighway that's the way you choose
to teach young children you don't teach
young children by putting them in front
of a computer and hoping that they learn
there are lots of responsibilities that
we have to teach children and they have
to do with interacting understanding the
rules how to get along with each other
knowing discipline and all of that I
don't believe you learn on the
information superhighway plugged into
technology so I think that is totally
the wrong direction for public education
you can use technology but technology
does not replace a highly qualified
teacher who knows the subject matter who
has been taught to work with children so
I think that is an entirely wrong
direction for our country we can use the
technology but it is a not
a replacement for high quality public
education thank you what do you think
well I think Carol brings up so many
really important points so I'd like to
start actually walk backwards if I may
one of the things that's an issue that's
particularly close to my heart not just
when I first started out in research but
also from firsthand personal experience
it's become even more personal is the
issue of special education and one thing
that's so frustrating to me is when
parents who if they're in their chosen
public district or public charter school
and their children are receiving through
their individualized education plans or
programs the programs and services that
are working for them amen
that is fantastic but in far too many
cases parents who are in a government
schooling system and their parents can
see that their children are not
flourishing the services and the
education provided to their children
with special needs are not working for
their children and no you do not have to
have an alphabet soup of letters after
your name to know that my kid can't read
my kid is frustrated they're having
meltdowns every night and they go and
try and work within the public or
government system and they're they're up
against it's really a David and Goliath
situation because parents do not have
thirty to fifty thousand dollars you're
going to need to get the lawyers one of
the only increases in litigation the
public school litigation with parents is
special needs because parents are
fighting tooth and nail they are giving
everything they have and more going to
huge debt just to get their kids its
words but have special needs into the
programs that work absolutely false
and one thing that I'm just gonna be
very candid right here makes my blood
boil when I have to go before various
you know committee state committees
testifying about education savings
account
or scholarship programs whether it's tax
credit which is privately financed
scholarship programs or publicly funny
finance voucher programs depending on
the state and what's allowable under
their constitution
I hear free and appropriate education or
faith well you don't have the
protections under IDE a you know what I
want to say to that
it literally do not get a gold star
because it took an act of Congress to
force public schools to accept children
with special needs and some of the most
compelling testimony and I would urge
you to read it is actually someone in
the Ville Clinton's administration who
has polio and said I was kept out of New
York Public Schools that's where I
wanted to go I had to go to the Catholic
schools to receive my education because
I was in a wheelchair and I was told I
was a fire hazard so in 1975 we passed
what is now called the individuals with
Disabilities Education Act which
guarantees a free and appropriate public
education to all children the reason it
took ten act of Congress is because
millions of children were being turned
away from public or government schools
because they had disabilities so I am
all for if a district school works for
you fantastic
charter school homeschool online school
or through education savings accounts
which Arizona I'm very proud that my
home state was the first in the nation
in 2011 to have education savings
accounts which gave parents just 90
percent of their state funding their
state formula funding not the local not
specialized local or state funding or
federal funding to get their special
education children the combination of
services that would work for them and
guess what not only did they get the
tutoring and the services that they
needed they had money left over and you
know what the satisfaction rate was from
that education savings account program
where parents were just given a fraction
of what other children would get it was
a hundred percent
a hundred percent show me another
program anywhere in any marketplace or
any aspect of our lives where you have a
hundred percent so I understand the
ideals of eye-dea it is not working for
a lot of families and a lot of families
are shut out because they do not have
access to the big high-powered attorneys
to fight the system and it takes years
to go into court to get their kids the
services they need so if the government
system is working
fantastic more power to them but if it's
not do not keep these children trapped
give them education savings accounts to
get the products and services and
curricula they need mm-hmm
so I want to address maybe what Carol
said earlier about emotional
intelligence education as well this
seems to be more and more of a growing
importance in our world a lot of logic
can be automated with software not so
much emotion it's more difficult to
automate emotion so the the proximity of
very high level teachers to students is
crucial for the students development as
this technology access to computers for
the ones that do want to pursue that
obviously you only have a limited amount
of high level teachers and you have a
lot of students so it's difficult I
guess to figure out how to enable the
teachers that are very high level to
educate as many students or to create
better teachers in that sense for
students and just to piggyback off what
you were saying Vicki however we end up
funding schools this is this is
something property taxes are paying for
public schools
there's more specific heights versus
Bayview in San Francisco is just a good
way to put that into perspective well I
actually I think maybe I'll teach me
help you a little bit yeah please
because in California we have a
combination of funding for our public
schools
and what actually happens is that we
have a level that is set at the state so
if your property taxes don't meet that
level the state fills it in so that you
get a basic level of funding and then on
top of that for wealthier neighborhoods
they know absolutely wrong oh they get
cut well absolutely wrong so there was a
and I think this is probably one of the
most important things that's happened to
public education and it started out with
an idea called weighted student formula
and that means that kids who have
greater needs get more funding they
generate more funding and here in San
Francisco we actually started that
before the state changed that and so now
what we have is a system that every
school child every every child generates
a certain amount of money regardless of
whether you live in Bay View or you live
in Pacific Heights but if you happen to
be a foster child or you happen to be an
English language learner or you happen
to be low socioeconomics you generate
more money and so in fact schools that
have high percentages of our most needy
children get considerably more money so
that a child who lives in a school that
has a lot of children that that school
has thousands and thousands of dollars
more per student than a than a school
that doesn't have children that generate
that money so your premise is incorrect
but the parents can also help supplement
right the wealthy parents can supplement
their education financing no they can
well parents can't can can donate money
to a school and I think one of the the
strongest correlations between how well
kids do is income of parents and the
education of a mother and so
there's been a lot of study that says
you know if your mother has a college
degree and has had read to your child
your child will be better prepared for
school and that's one of the reasons why
in addition to having a weighted student
formula we're moving to much greater
investment in early education because we
know that there is a huge disparity
between the opportunity of a child who
lives in Pacific Heights and a child who
lives in an area where the income is
lower and so a very important investment
that we should be making as communities
is investment in early education for all
our children so all of our children have
the opportunity to learn and when they
get to kindergarten they're not behind
and so I think that's in a very
essential role of our communities and
our state to ensure that we do
everything we can to even the playing
field so the children come to school
ready to learn and I would say it's very
interesting listening to Carol because
obviously their research is very
interesting on this point and I was
thinking well my mother was a high
school dropout who made Harvard
professors cry she's part of an artist
commune and she dropped out because her
father died so she's being raised by a
single mom who had an eighth-grade
education by the way we're the Boston
Irish Catholics who were responsible for
Blaine amendments so if you want to know
why you can't have vouchers for k-12 but
you can't have them for higher education
and my people are personally responsible
for that so so why don't we just explain
because people might not know what lay
in the mail oh thank you yes yes a
Blaine amendment there what I would
consider lights on our state
constitutions many of our state
constitutions particularly in the ways
of Western states that say no public
funding for private education at the
k-12 level of course at college you can
18
olds can take public dollars and go
wherever they want public private
religious non-religious see we're
looking at the same glass
she says it's half-empty and I say it's
more than half-full because I think that
making sure that public money goes to
pay for public education is probably one
of the most important principles of
Education and that it shouldn't be
diverted for private profit to pay for
private and religious schools and so I
think we'll agree to disagree oh yeah
but I would like to bring up something
that's really unique about California's
history pardon me
because when we're going into the what
are called the equity lawsuits during
the early 70s and I had the distinct
pleasure of meeting personally some of
the lawyers off the record they call so
you know he called himself the wee
Bolsheviks from Berkeley who fought
those equity lawsuits and who were
responsible for really driving across
the country the fact that different
children in different parts of the state
costs more not all areas pardon me have
the same property wealth and I love that
sort of equity but here's what's very
interesting about folks who oppose
vouchers at which are publicly financed
scholarships at the k-12 level not at
the higher ed level because I don't hear
these same people voting against or
railing against Pell grants or the GI
Bill if you look at that case in
California the judge actually said
because the ones who litigated the case
said we would like in essence Pell
grants for k-12 kids because we would
break down those economic barriers to
equality so kids could take that money
and just just go to school it goes all
the way back to Thomas Paine take that
money and go to school we don't care
where you're educated just get educated
and talking about let me jump in for a
second yes cuz I want to follow and I
and follow-on about the weighted student
formula because it's so important and
one thing that I am really surprised
about that in California you don't have
disability weights in your formula
you've just converted to the local
control formula you don't have various
categories of disabilities well I can I
can address that too but yes yes let's
go to that please let's go back a little
bit to your discussion of vouchers
mm-hmm and one of the things about
people getting money taking public money
to go to a private school and here's the
big difference public schools are open
to everyone you don't have to pay to go
to a public school private schools they
pick and choose they can decide whether
or not they're going to accept you and
so I think your argument is not an
equity argument because poor children
who don't have enough money to pay for
the tuition and the vouchers that people
provided certainly weren't close to the
40 or 50 thousand dollars you're paying
for an expensive independent school here
in San Francisco it's it's a no-go and
in fact what we have had twice in
California because this was such an
interesting issue as we put it by
initiative to the public and the public
twice overwhelmingly said public money
should pay for public schools and that
is the direction that we have been
working on and I really appreciate you
bringing up the initiatives and the
debates because they're important
debates and can I tell you how nice it
is to be up here and we clearly did not
see we share very different points of
view
I'm glad not once you said why do you
hate children because there's so many
times it's why do you hate public
education why do you hate this
I just want to
to interject and say I appreciate that
but I'd like to because we hear these
debates and they're their debates we're
going to hear much more frequently
where's the specific place that you
disagree though let me go jump in okay
for a second and I and I think that
there's something here that we all agree
on and that we all agree on passionately
and that is we have to provide all of
our children with a quality education
there is no disagreement and I I don't
think that there's a heart in here
that's saying you know you can't don't
do this one don't do that one we're here
for a public good and the reason I came
here is because this really is one of
the most important discussions that's
happening in the nation and it's about
the direction of where we go with
education and I think it's important for
us to be having this conversation about
what that direction is and I think we
can talk a little bit because I think
it's one of the issues we have to talk
about is is what do we do to make sure
that we have quality schools because the
issue I don't think is choice choice
doesn't equal quality choices you can
choose a bad school you can choose a
good school you can choose something
that's green you can choose something
they're bred it doesn't matter that it's
the choice it's the quality of the
school and I think that's what we need
to be talking about and I won't have
that conversation but I want to jump
back to two points as you were saying
where do we disagree first I want to
just go right to the jugular public
schools are open to all those you know
those private schools that charge forty
thousand dollars which we'll get to in a
moment they pick and choose those are
arguments we've been hearing for decades
and decades and decades number one if
you're in the state of Arizona actually
let me step back I do not buy for a
nanosecond a nanosecond the argument
that in a state that
rations public education by kids zip
codes where your parents can afford
can't afford to live is where you have
your choices let's say that I am in
right out I'm in South San Francisco but
I want to go to one of the better public
schools in San Francisco or other places
I maybe have more of a choice than in
Sacramento or in LA but guess who calls
the shots
district officials so do not tell me
when you still have a state and this is
as you can hear my voice changing this
enrages me that in the 21st century we
still ration education by where families
can afford to live is insane you want to
have better quality education you want
have better educational opportunity you
want to desegregate schools you want all
of the good things I think everyone in
this room would agree on tear down the
walls that keep kids segregated by where
their parents can afford to live do not
assign children in education based on
zip codes we could not come up with a
stupid stupider more unjust system if we
put all of our brains together second
thing I want to address is this notion
that oh those big bad $40,000 private
schools that pick and choose there are
more than 63 non-public parental choice
programs where they are publicly funded
vouchers whether they are privately
funded tax credit scholarship programs
or educational savings accounts programs
the overwhelming majority of non public
schools who participate are religious
and some of them just like all those
private schools that DC politicians and
presidents and their kids - they are
open to poor kids
so this cherry-picking argument is utter
garbage because the overwhelming
majority of private schools that
participate
in choice programs and I've done the
research on it it's not ability to pay
so I'm not going to accept that the pick
and choose argument when we live in is
when we are in a state that rations
education based on where families can
afford to live in maybe a counter to
that I guess I could I just read this
research put out by the Learning Policy
Institute on school choice and I thought
it was very interesting because they
looked at what are the kinds of choices
that you have in a various system and so
there are many choices within a public
school system you can have a magnet
school you can have your neighborhood
school you can have a music school you
can have an art school you can't have a
high school that that does this certain
thing you can have a school that
partners with a community college there
are lots of different ways of slicing
and dicing public school choice the
other thing that I've just been looking
at and I think that what we we just
heard was sort of a conflict
conflagration of choice meeting quality
because when you look for example at the
data and we can argue over this research
or that research but there is a large
amount of research that looks at voucher
programs that looks at charter school
programs that looks at virtual school
programs that looks at for-profit school
programs and if I were sitting here and
the research told me that wow this is
the Silver Bullet after 10 or 15 years
we have finally figured out
the Silver Bullet well the research
tells us hey folks private school choice
vouchers all of those are not a silver
bullet there are good charter schools
there are some good schools to take
vouchers mostly all the schools fall in
the middle where they're about the same
as your neighborhood public schools and
then there are loads of schools that go
out of business that are terrible and so
the idea that there is some great
synergy that this choice has over these
last 15 or 20 years made a huge
difference in the quality of school is
something we have to get past I think
what we have to look at and it's true
for a public school skew for a private
schools true for a charter school there
are certain things that we have to make
sure that all our children have one of
them is a high quality teacher and
whether you agree with it or disagree
with it I happen to think that a teacher
who's trained to be a teacher and
certified as a teacher probably is a
little better than it than someone who
is in a school who has never but had any
training to be a teacher I think other
things that are important is that we
have to start and I and this is an issue
that that's statewide and it's national
and that is that because of many
economic forces we have not been
investing in our teachers teachers are
paid considerably less than comparable
people with college degrees and so we
have a teacher shortage and one of the
big changes that we have to have to look
at in terms of private schools or public
schools is investing in high quality
teachers and so high quality teachers is
like number one on
my list of making sure that our schools
are doing well and then of course we
have to have you know safe facilities we
have to have professional development
and we have to have I believe a broad
curriculum that meets the needs of all
of our children and so when I look for
example at what are the what are some of
the problems that we've had in our
school system it has been driven and I
think we agree on this
in large part on a school system that
has been pushed and shoved by high test
high-stakes testing and so I think the
move away from high-stakes testing the
move towards more local control in your
communities the move for decisions to be
made engaging parents all of those
things are going to improve education
and one of the I think the the most
important things that we have to talk
about is engaged parents engage as
someone who's been involved with a PTA
for a long time we know that parents who
are engaged in their students education
those kids do better and so I think
those are some points of agreement
rather than arguing over some other
issues I think we need to look at what
are those things that are common values
and gosh where to began so many good
points really very important points I
think starting with engaged parents and
that is critically important and I think
and that's why San Francisco this is I
think this is a good place to be having
this conversation because San Francisco
I think to a large extent more so than
many other places in California does
give parents options we made a group we
we may disagree on how many more options
we could give parents but I think
involve Parenthood starts from the very
beginning of the choice about where your
child not just where your child goes to
school but how your child is educated so
for me I'm going to tell you right now
you want to go to a government or
district public school great public
charter school homeschool unschool
private school or religious God is it
right for your child that's all I care
about the question of quality because
this is something that I have to tell
you starts getting me very nervous
because if you look at the folks who
want to do high-stakes testing and argue
about well we need common core goals
2000 whatever the Silver Bullet because
I think we both agree there are no
silver bullets in education well I think
we would agree that there are some
elements when put together create the
quality quality schools certainly you
can't you know certainly we can talk
about that but when we certainly look at
the newspapers in the political realm
well let's just find the one fix and
then just get that seed out of water and
we can have we can just replicate it
that's not how it works
but if we want involve parents we have
to have options and we're going to talk
about quality quality is measured by
each individual child and where they
start from and where they can go parents
who are children's first educators
having a positive cooperative working
relationship with their children's
teachers can get their children so much
farther and that's where I think the
role of testing comes in in the form of
Diagnostics here's where you started
here's where you go here are the
strengths here the weaknesses let's work
together take all of that training and
all of that pedagogy and all that
experience and let's work together
that's what's going to have children to
succeed and it has to be on a voluntary
basis so I think if we start
there and I actually this is sort of an
interesting issue I have something
really crucial to bring up there yeah
we're getting out almost close there and
there's definitely a couple things that
that I think we're really important to
address before we do start opening up
for Q&A I think probably the most
important thing is exponential
technology so we're now in an era of
artificial intelligence and robotics as
well as biotechnology exploding neuro
technology exploding space technology
blockchain and cryptocurrency all these
different technologies are exploding
into the world and public schools and
for even private schools in many cases
not equipped for this a lot of parents
philosophies are just like hey I birthed
this child into the world and I'm just
going to drop it off at the curb and
hope for the best a lot of actually what
we teach on our program is that it's
actually more so that the parent is the
deity to the child that the pates the
parents responsibility first and
foremost to be an exceptional educator
to the child and then to have an
Augmented education extended from family
and friends and teachers and community
as well so with this exponential
technology age it's becoming more and
more along the lines of the little the
little human the passes the Turing test
you can't tell whether it's a human or a
robot that is available 24/7 full access
to Wikipedia fully customized to your
child available anytime and teaching
your child at home on the road wherever
it it wherever you are what are your
thoughts about that I think it's a lot
of hooey I like the I like the
availability of information for
education information is not education
another thing and I'm I'm talking as a
stepmom to 4-step sons who are on the
computer all the time very closely
monitored by the way the minor children
are monitored their learning languages
they're learning all sorts of things
it's a wonderful opportunity however
information is an education and another
thing
I think with all these tools it breaks
down so many barriers so if you live in
a rural area my gosh you can have access
to an MIT professor really great
possibilities but I also want to be very
careful because there are a lot of
companies that are making lots of money
off of children whose parents are not
being informed whether it's social
emotional learning adaptive learning all
these other things my step kiddos for an
example are not for sale they're not
guinea pigs and if you would like to
advance research we're happy to
participate in the research I'm a
researcher get our consent so I think
there are so many great possibilities
there could be great equalizers but be
very honest about what you're doing what
you're collecting about our kids because
the privacy concerns privacy breaches
and what's being collected on people's
children every day and people making a
profit off it
anyone of it the profit is the secondary
I don't like it what are you doing to
people's children without parental
consent and then treating parents
putting parents on the sidelines that's
where parents have to be first of all so
when I say it's a lot of hooey a lot of
what you said it is is I agree with but
I think that when we look at what is the
purpose of Education the purpose is more
than having a child who can you know do
high calculus and look up something at
MIT or whatever it would be I think the
purpose of Education is is much broader
but that's not what I said whatsoever
and actually I didn't mention
information being the key I mentioned
education being the key and the
abundance of any education across social
or emotional or intellectual learn
accessed at any time personalized to the
student this is a new era that I just
don't know I'm not saying that that
there are not great possibilities but I
don't think that we should fool
ourselves that technology is going to
teach our children what it's like to go
to school with someone who's a different
religion or someone who looks
differently than they are but this is
are really being donor or whose parents
have different socio economics or who
speak a different language or who have
to learn how to work with other on
projects who have to learn what empathy
is all of those interpersonal skills
require people they require teachers
they require nurturing and I don't think
that any of that can be replaced by what
you're talking about I'm not saying that
you can't use technology but what I'm
saying is the idea that that kind of
technology will replace how do you
socialize a four or five year old to
work and become a responsible citizen I
don't think it will I think you need
personal interaction I'm gonna disagree
because I'm actually living that right
now and I had some time to really live
it during the country's largest teacher
walkout in Arizona with my youngest
stepson and my other stepsons two-degree
he's on that to her computer all the
time but it isn't just checking out he
is communicating with other people from
all over the world
his russians better than mine and I went
to university for years to learn Russian
he picked it up at like a week big of a
super risky all right he learned this
languages he learns computer technology
he he can explain nuclear fission to me
so there actually is a way to
personalize learning and one thing
that's I never and I'm being very
cautious here because personalized
learning I think I understand the
context your meaning of it your your
meaning it I like the idea that and I'm
thinking my youngest stepson right now
it could apply to all of them but I
would really like the fact that just
because he's going into middle school
and he's not in high school he can't be
taking the advanced calculus that he's
already doing getting college credit I
would like him to have the opportunity
and to be within groups online
communities because online communities
are communities and you do have that
kind of diversity yes it is a challenge
having boys get off the computer go out
and actually have one-on-one
non-wrestling interaction so that's
that's always a challenge but I think
there's huge possibility as long as
number one it's voluntary that the
personalization is directed by parents
without any other outside influences
trying to gather data on
social-emotional for example think about
what your kid is learning right now and
your kid doesn't tell you everything
that they're learning it would take you
know take you weeks to even just start
chipping away at what they're learning
versus machine will learn very quickly
about what your child's preferences are
and then they're able to further advance
your child's education that way faster
and I'd be ok with that as long as
number one the parents what's being
collected is absolutely transparent it's
not going to the you know Department of
Labor in DC because I don't think
children are worker bees we don't have a
planned economy I don't want that so
that sort of feedback that is voluntary
not being collected yeah I there can be
some benefit of it but I want to be very
cautious about it so let me just jump in
a little bit because I'm not saying it's
not an opportunity I want to be clear
about that but I don't think it's a
replacement either and and the other
thing I think there's a a word of
caution because there has been a lot of
research about virtual
online charter schools that are
primarily in the per for profit space
and the research is overwhelming in in
many ways one of the things that it's
found is that kids who are doing well
who are curious who are self-starters
who are independent that is works better
for them than for a child who's
struggling and the research also says
that for a virtual school virtual
schools really don't do well unless
there are frequent personal check-ins
with real people in person looking at
each other to help particularly the
children that are struggling and so for
those virtual learning experiences they
work well for the child who's at the
high end who is highly motivated but
generally they don't work well for many
of the children who are in those virtual
schools who are struggling the other
thing that the research has been
overwhelmingly clear about is that the
results of how well children do in a
virtual for-profit school are really
much worse than how well children do in
a non-profit school in person so there's
a huge discrepancy so when you start
talking about
oh we're gonna use technology magic and
it's going to somehow do all of this
stuff I think that we have to remember
that where we're working with children
who need support reassurance nurturing
and that sort of thing and and virtual
online click an app learn something is
not a replacement for those
interpersonal skills and and sense of
Independence and that would that we need
to develop in our children and I think
Carol brought up a good point but I also
want to make a clarification we do
computers quick because I want to
we we always need the interpersonal
computers technology robots are never
going to replace but I just want to make
a clarification about for profit versus
nonprofit I've worked at it I've been on
a board of a charter school very
successful charter school that is now
technically for-profit it's a legal
definition it's just a legal that's a
designation that makes things easier so
I want to be careful of nonprofit vs.
for-profit hey if you do a great job
educate my kid and you can make a you
can make a profit with my consent I
don't care about that
so I want to be very careful about the
somehow pardon me that making a profit
is somehow evil in the education sector
it isn't evil anywhere else because
making a profit is what pays the taxes
that supports the public school sector
so I just want to be careful of that
sort of language
so we've chiseled away at point zero
zero one percent of what's going on in
the education sector it's so difficult
to unpack everything and shut in such a
short period of time what is maybe a
really important takeaway that people
can maybe make action on do you want to
go first you let me go first oh thank
you I would say that don't believe in
one-size-fits-all
don't believe in silver bullets I think
the best way to measure success of any
educational setting is by each
individual child so our individual
children flourishing and do parents have
optimal freedom complete freedom over
how and where their children are
educated that's a signal of success for
me and that's absolutely where we should
be going it's a hard question what what
should be the takeaway I think that the
takeaway for me is that as a community
we have a really important
responsibility and that is to educate
all of our children and that our
community and you may call them
government schools I like to call them
public schools public schools that are
open to everyone have have a
responsibility to meet the needs of
every child wherever they live whatever
their income whatever language they
speak whatever ability or disability
that they have that's what public
education is for and it is the entrance
and the opportunity for all children to
meet and and gain the skills that they
need to be successful adults and my
preference obviously is that public
money be used to pay for public schools
that are open to every child and just a
thought from from me I really appreciate
the understanding of information
superhighways education superhighways
because it's about expanding the mind to
these new dimensions of thought and we
have no idea how to fund them and how to
get them to all SES but what I can say
is that democratizing information and
making it accessible it's an equal
opportunity to that education is
probably the most important takeaway
from for me Thank You Carol Vicki thank
you so much for coming on thank you
[Applause]
[Music]